[Music]
welcome to this lecture on the basics of
defined benefit pensions a lot of you
have probably thought about the problem
of your own saving for your own
retirement in say 401K plans but another
form of retirement benefit is a monthly
payment provided by an employer to a
worker that begins when that worker re
retires this is called a defined benefit
or DB pension because the monthly
retirement benefit the employee receives
is defined and known in advance who has
DB pensions in the US the latest data
tell us that only about 177% of private
sector employees participate in DB
pension plans in contrast 78% of state
or local government employees and also
many federal government employees
participate in DB plans if we contrast
this to defined contribution or DC plans
such as the 401K we see that private
sector employees are much more likely to
participate in a DC plan over 40% of
them do whereas only 15% of public
sector employees participate in DC plans
we can also compare this to access
figures that is who has access to these
plans and who participates just about
everyone who has access to a DB plan
seems to participate in it they seem to
think it's a good deal on the other hand
if all private sector workers with
access to DC plans participated in those
plans there would be DC participation
rates of closer to 60% as opposed to
40% now at this point some small group
of you is saying great I'm involved in a
DB plan I have one so this is right up
my alley others of you might be saying I
don't have a DB pension so why should I
care well if you are a US citizen your
federal state and possibly local
government employs people and in most
cases offers them d DB pensions that
means that actually you employ them and
offer DB pensions so if you're a
taxpayer it's going to be important to
understand these Arrangements since you
as the employer are also offering them
to your
employees one way to begin to think
about the DB plans whether you're one of
the citizens who has one or whether
you're one of the citizens who as a
taxpayer offers one to government
employees is to imagine that you wanted
to try to pay yourself a DB pension when
you retire say if something like 30 ,000
per year well you might start out by
imagining that you could just save in
your 401k and then when you retire you
could buy an annuity from an insurance
company but if you invest in Risky
Assets in the 401K you have no way of
guaranteeing yourself any particular
level of benefit because you don't know
how these risky assets are going to
perform even if you had been investing
in Risk free Assets in your 401k you
couldn't have known what interest rates
would be when you retire
so for example arriving at retirement
with a balance of say
$500,000 that would allow you to provide
a much higher stream of monthly
consumption for yourself if interest
rates are 10% when you get there than if
they are 1% the only way you could pay
yourself a guaranteed benefit at
retirement would have been to buy
yourself a deferred annuity a financial
product that gives you a stream of fixed
or an index stream of payments beginning
at some future date so thinking about
from the perspective of an employee who
has one of these DB plans a DB pension
eliminates a lot of the uncertainty
however on the other side of the coin is
that the employer must figure out how to
provide this guaranteed stream of
payments the savings and investment
problem for how to do that is now in the
hands of the employer not the employee
and this highlights one crucial
difference between the employer problem
preparing to provide DB payments for
employees in retirement and the
employees problem if if he or she is
saving in a 401k or other type of plan
for his or her own retirement as an
individual or household if you decide to
invest in Risky Assets in your 401k well
you can scale up or down your
consumption in retirement if the assets
perform better or worse than you expect
if the assets perform really well in
your 401k well maybe you can buy that
boat you always wanted without scaling
back your lifestyle in other ways if the
assets perform poorly you might not only
be unable to buy the boat you might have
to downsize your apartment and spend
less money going out to dinner so if
your 401k assets don't do well you
basically just pay yourself a smaller
consumption stream in retirement in
contrast if you as a taxpayer an
employer of public employees are
sponsoring a DB plan that invests in
Risky assets and those assets do not
perform as hoped for or expected you the
employer still has to provide the same
consumption stream the employer in a
traditional DB plan cannot tell the
employees sorry the assets did poorly so
I'm scaling back your pension doing that
would be a violation of the contract
between the employer and the employee
and it would be viewed as a default on
an obligation a default that could only
be legal perhaps if the employer entered
some kind of legal bankruptcy
proceedings more on that later so if the
employee is expecting a pension that
would allow her to say buy a boat
whether a small one or a large one and
the assets and the employer DB pension
fund perform less than expectations the
employee does not have to scale back her
plans to buy the boat the employer or
you the taxpayer must come up with the
money one way or another if it's a
government then out of increased revenue
or spending cuts in addition to
sponsoring government employee pensions
one other area where many people have
exposure to DB pension risk is through
the shares of stock that you invest in
while only 177% of private sector
employees participate in DB plans there
are still many companies that are
carrying around Legacy DB promises
there's older promises that they owe to
older active employees and retirees and
in some cases even offering to new
employees if the firm finds itself
having a shortfall in the assets
required to pay to pay the pensions then
that shortfall must come out of
corporate profits and hence out of
shareholder
value so if you have a DB plan if you're
in one then this lecture should be
helpful for understanding what benefits
you are entitled to if you do not have a
DB plan then this lecture should help
you understand the nature of the DB
promises you have implicitly made to
others either as a taxpayer or a
shareholder whether you know it or not
you are an employer who offers employees
DB pension plans that means that you
have to instruct your delegates
particularly city councils and state
legislatures to make decisions about
various aspects of the DB pension
contract and you need to understand what
pensions you owe contractually for every
employee today as well as what pensions
you're likely to owe given the
probability that your Workforce will
continue to earn pension rights in the
future and you shouldn't just assume
that someone else is going to do this
work for you in a way that represents
your best interests maybe they will but
maybe they
[Music]
won't